let's continue coding our content
provider query will be the most complex
of the required content provider methods
we begin with the bones of the query
operation we use our s URI matcher
object once again to switch on the type
of URI this is the only function where
we will have to fill out every type of
URI in the content provider as several
of them are used for querying only we'll
implement the basic weather query first
for this query we just pass through all
of the parameters to the database pretty
simple stuff let's fix these parameters
so they make some sense so the strings
here is actually a projection as is a
selection the next array is selection
ours in the last string is sort order
that matches a lot better at the bottom
of the function we're going to set the
notification URI for our cursor to the
one that was passed into the function
this causes the cursor to register a
Content observer to watch for changes
that happen to that URI and any of its
descendants by descendants I mean any
URI that begins with this path but we
still need to test this